on est au complexe desjardins ou comme
vous voyez le père noël est extrêmement
sollicité j'ai donc demandé à des luttes
et la culture de lui donner un coup de
main en nous faisant quelques
suggestions de cadeaux
du côté franco le nouvel album des
cowboys fringants les antipodes c'est un
incontournable retour en force pour les
cowboys bravo les cow boys puis la
phénomène de l'année ces bleus jean
blues et uba ton quant au matin et puis
pour papa et maman la reddition du 45e
anniversaire du premier album
d'harmonium les grosses tourne là dessus
du côté anglophone spots choix qui
manque
la pièce maîtresse le mammouth sur la
reddition 50e anniversaire de l'elbe
lead des rolling stones un
incontournable
les testaments de margaret atwood qui a
remporté cette année le booker prize
prix très prestigieux pour ce livre-là
qui est la suite de la servante écarlate
du côté québécois en un ellis turcotte
qui nous a donné cette année
l'apparition du chevreuil est paru chez
alto donc un roman québécois très fort
un roman qui est déjà parmi les
nominations pour le prix france-québec
2020 c'est la dernière année de kent
nagano à la direction du wasen alors
tous les concerts que dirigera kent
nagano ont une valeur particulière alors
moi ce que je vous recommande
c'est le cycle schubert qui va présenter
en janvier ou février avec loin simple
deuxième suggestion l'année 2020 selanne
et beethoven beethoven aurait 250 ans en
2020 ce que je vous recommande c'est ce
sont les concerts avec le pianiste louis
lortie à la salle bourgie louis lortie
présente l'intégrale des sonates de
beethoven en mythe concert je vous
propose l'exposition immersive imagine
20 go qui est présentée à la galerie
arsenal à montréal actuellement et qui
sera présenté du côté québec au mois de
juin
pourquoi ne pas offrir du matériel
d'artiste pour stimuler la créativité et
que l'an prochain ce soit ses oeuvres
qui se retrouvent s'il s'appelle messi
des biens etc sans chartier radio canada
montréal